voici le véhicule dans lequel se
trouvait un homme d'une quarantaine
d'années avant qu'il ne soit foudroyé
par un infarctus
heureusement un professeur de
gymnastique alertés par le bruit de la
voiture affaissé sur mur situé en face
de l'école à courre constatant une
anomalie dans la respiration du
conducteur la jeune femme tente les
premiers gestes
j'étais sur le plateau sportif avec mes
élèves et nous avons entendu un bruit
donc j'ai vu une dame sortir de la
voiture se dirigeait vers le conducteur
et j'ai vu que sa tête était penché donc
je suis tout de suite sorti de
l'établissement scolaire pour effecter
les premiers soins et madame m'a rejoint
et nous avons ensemble essayé de
réanimer le monsieur donc quand on a
plus senti son push et procédé au
massage cardiaque les pompiers et les
urgentistes arrivés sur place prennent
ensuite le relais massage injection
l'équipe médicale finira par stabiliser
l'état du patient pour les gestes en lui
en serai là vivre on va voir si on peut
encore lui sauver la vie pour l'instant
c'est pour l'instant à déstabiliser
c'est tout ce qu'on peut dire a priori
oui oui ça lui sauve la vie du soleil
malgré notre insistance l'humilité de la
jeune femme la pousse à vouloir rester
anonyme c'est pas se mettre en avant
c'est faire son devoir et faire le
maximum pour sauver les autres tout
simplement voulait toujours pas qu'on
vous voit le conducteur sera évacuée au
chum grâce aux cocos de la sécurité
civile où les équipes médicales
tenteront de lui déboucher les artères
entre temps les membres de la famille
arrivée sur place le tarde pas compte de
l'importance du geste et exprimons avec
émotion leurs connaissances à l'héroïne
du jour
là